Isn’t learning fun?
I absolutely love it.
For the past 15 years, I have been
an academic writing instructor,
and I've been a coach for the last five.
The people that I usually work with
are adults who've returned to school,
and I really love working with these folks
because, like them,
I'm a lifelong learner,
and I've been to school three times,
so far, in the past 20 years.
But I still remember
the first time that I went back.
I almost quit, the first semester.
By midterm, I was collapsed
into this shabby chair
in my prof's office, in the corner,
in the midst of an existential crisis.
Things were going horribly.
The seminars that I so diligently
prepared for were painful.
Every time we were asked for our responses
and analysis of the readings,
everyone else's responses
sounded so smart.
Mine, by comparison, seemed so basic.
And then, I got my first paper back ...
and I'd bombed it.
Yep. (Laughs)
So there I was, in tears,
convinced that I was the dumbest,
least capable person in the class.
And honestly, I got to tell you,
I was ready to quit.
But I had actually staked a lot
on going back to school.
I had actually quit my best job to date
to pursue my dream
of becoming an instructor.
So I wanted my prof’s advice
before I made any final decisions.
She handed me some tissues,
and instead of agreeing
with my assessment,
she told me to stick it out.
And she said that apparently,
I wasn't doing any worse than anyone else.
Now, I was pretty skeptical,
because all the evidence
seemed to point to the contrary.
But figuring she knew
something that I didn't,
I held on.
By the end of term, she was right.
My grades began to improve,
and I learned that my fellow students
were just as overwhelmed as I was.
Needless to say, this experience
has stayed with me,
and it has informed how I teach and coach.
I've been where my prof was
and said the same things
to my students and clients.
I've also learned a lot since then
about the relationship
between confidence and learning.
Nowadays, the mid-career
professionals who come to me
for help with their academic success
come to me because they think
they have a skill problem.
And sure, they could use
some skill-building for sure.
But for many, that's
not the crux of the issue
that's getting in the way
of their success.
The real issue lies in how they think
about themselves as learners
and what they believe to be true
about their abilities.
Now, this might seem like a bold claim,
so let me explain.
Why aren't skills the real issue?
Most of us are very capable learners.
The people I work with
are accomplished professionals
and experts in their field.
They wouldn't be where they are
if they didn't know
how to learn and build skills.
When I went back, I had been writing
and training for several years
in a professional context.
My challenge was up-leveling my analytical
and critical thinking skills.
Once I was oriented to that gap,
I set about closing it.
My grades began to improve.
I see the same thing
with my students and clients.
Bridging the skill gap
is easier than we think.
It's the confidence gap
that is much harder to bridge.
But it needs addressing
because that is what is getting in the way
of our academic success
in learning situations.
So what's going on
with our confidence anyway?
What is happening? Why is it so hard?
Based on my experience,
adults in learning situations
face three main challenges.
The first one is that we struggle
with a lot of self doubt and uncertainty.
For many of us who go back,
the learning curve is really steep.
It's not only been years, maybe decades,
since we'd been back in school.
We've spent a hot minute or two
since we've been a beginner at anything.
All of a sudden, we find ourselves
having to navigate online platforms
and figure out study habits,
and this whole academic writing thing
is a whole next level.
And then, we have to read critically.
It's a lot.
And then add to this
that when we return to school,
we often bring with us
all the old patterns and beliefs
that we've been carrying
for the past ten, maybe 20 years,
about who we are as learners.
In the past, if we thought
that we were weak students,
we've already got bags of doubts
and insecurities and anxieties,
and we judge ourselves harshly
right out of the gate.
Now if you’re thinking,
“I was a good student, I got this,” --
no, no.
We struggle because we can
set the bar unreasonably high
and then judge ourselves
just as harshly and as quickly.
And it's difficult.
The second challenge that we face
is that we spend a lot of time
comparing ourselves to everyone else.
Now, this is a really human thing to do,
and it's a very easy pit to fall into
for high-achieving adults.
Because, let's face it, we want to know
that we can at least keep up with
or do better than our peers.
But when we compare ourselves
to other folks,
it can be paralyzing,
because we can fall into thinking
that we are less than them.
This is especially true when people
start sharing grades and progress reports.
We can go from feeling accomplished
and on top of things
to feeling behind and confused,
in a matter of minutes.
And the third challenge that we face
is that we have a strong fear of failing.
Now, for most of the folks who go back,
we've got a lot on the line.
We're juggling a job and family
responsibilities alongside school.
Plus, we want to do well,
because we're usually there
to up-level our career
or hit a career goal in some way,
to say nothing of the time
and the financial investments involved.
So being afraid of failing, well,
it's understandable, right?
But it is an obstacle to getting
the very thing that we want.
So those are the challenges.
There is good news, though.
These can be overcome
by making three important mindset shifts
when we are in learning situations.
The first shift is that we really need
to question the stories
that our brain is telling us
about who we are as learners.
Every day, we have a ton of thoughts,
and we often don't stop to examine them.
But when we do, we notice that often
most of them are really unhelpful.
And this is especially true
when we are pushing ourselves
out of our comfort zone.
Our brain interprets the challenges
and discomforts that come with learning
and trying new things
as dangerous,
and it wants to move us
into what is familiar and safe.
So the way that it does that
is it amplifies all of our fears
and cranks the volume on our inner critic,
who's more than happy to tell us
all the ways we sucked in the past,
how we're not doing it now,
and there's no hope for the future.
Our job is to notice these stories
and why they're happening --
because we're stretching --
and to challenge these outdated beliefs.
So when we question
the truthfulness and the relevance
of the stories that we're carrying
for who we are in our current context,
and choose more accurate and helpful ones,
we can change our entire experience.
The second shift that we need to make
is that we need to look
for the lessons in the mistakes.
As learners, we are
going to make mistakes.
We just are.
Rather than making them mean something
about our current or our future ability,
or our self-worth, for that matter,
we need to get curious
and look at these setbacks
as offering data
that we can use to improve.
And part of being curious
is remembering that the mistakes
are where the learning happens.
And that's what we need to aim for --
progress, not perfection.
When we release ourselves
from the need to know it all,
be perfect and do it all perfectly,
we are much better able
to evaluate our progress
and actually identify
the skills we need to build
for the outcome that we want.
And then finally,
the third shift we need to make
is to practice self-compassion,
not self-criticism.
Learning and pushing
ourselves to our growth edge,
it's uncomfortable work.
It's not easy.
And that's why this shift
is the most important one,
because it's actually the fuel
for our success.
When we stop criticizing ourselves
and start showing ourselves the kindness
and the compassion
that we so easily give everyone else ...
we are much more likely to take risks,
because we create
a sense of safety inside ourselves,
that it's OK to make mistakes
and learn from them.
And when we remember
that we're imperfectly human,
and that our fellow students
are also imperfect humans,
we’re less likely
to compare ourselves to them
and more likely to connect
and collaborate with them instead.
When we cultivate a belief
inside ourselves
and show ourselves compassion,
we increase our ability to face challenges
and learn from them.
And we build the resilience
and the confidence
that we need to succeed
in learning situations.
And from that foundation,
we are better able to identify
the skills we have --
and we do, by the way --
the ones we need to hone
and the ones that we need.
Closing the confidence gap
enables us to reach our goals,
feeling accomplished and proud
rather than bedraggled and depleted.
My experience and my work has convinced me
that when we build
a positive growth mindset
alongside our skills
in learning situations,
not only do we increase
our success -- like, intensely --
we uncage our fullest potential,
and our possibilities for change
and growth are limitless.
Thank you very much.
(Cheers and applause)